the people you look up to
are going to form your vision of what
the world you know how you want to be in
later life part of life is getting
prepared
so that
when something does happen that's
significant you can grasp the
significance of it and know what to do
with it i mean i figured out very early
you don't have to be that smart of this
business which is fortunate but you do
have to have the right temperament
need motivation watch your top 10 with
believe nation top 10.
hey it's evan carmichael and i make
these videos because you are probably
the most ambitious person in your circle
but you know you're capable of more and
you get that push by surrounding
yourself with the best so today let's
learn from one of the best warren
buffett and my take on his top 10 rules
to success enjoy okay let's kick it off
with rule number one use your potential
the habits you develop and and i go back
the other thing is have the right heroes
i mean i've always been lucky in that
respect and
if you know if you the people you look
up to
are going to form your vision of what
the world you know how you want to be in
later life and the one
well i'll give you two pieces of advice
i'd invest as much in myself as you can
i mean you're your own biggest asset by
far i mean you've got you've got all
kinds of potential all the people in
this room you know you're lucky to be in
this country gotten a good education
but
most people go through life using up a
very very small part of their potential
and so anything you do that invests in
yourself uh
is that's the best investment you can
possibly make rule number two don't get
itchy there can be all kinds of
wonderful investment opportunities out
there that i don't understand i don't
know what cocoa beans are going to do
next year you know maybe you know but i
don't know i i don't know what i don't
know what uh crude oil is going to sell
for
but
i don't have to know
i just have to know the things i have to
know what i know
i have to know where the limits of my
understanding are
what i call what my circle of competence
is
and if i'm only able to evaluate five
percent of the businesses in the world
no problem i just stay within that five
percent and try and find something
uh and that's most people get in trouble
because
in investments because they
uh well they get itchy you know they
can't discipline themselves and they
hear about other people making money
nothing upsets people so much as to hear
about their friends making money i mean
it's that that's very destructive to
discipline because they think i'm
smarter than that guy next door and he
just just bought that new car with the
money made trading stocks on the
internet so why can't i well the answer
is you can't over time you will lose
money if you trade stocks actively
and uh
it's it's hard to exercise the
discipline
but anytime you buy something
you should be able to take out a
one-page sheet of paper
and say i'm buying general motors it's
65. i'm buying general electric 150
because
and you should write down the reasons if
you can't if you can't fill out the
sheet
if it's because somebody told me about
it at a cocktail party last night that's
not good enough if it's because my
broker told me about it that's not good
enough
yeah it's uh you've got to have a reason
for thinking that it makes an
intelligent investment you do the same
thing if you're buying a farm or an
apartment house if you're buying a farm
you'd say i'm buying this farm with a
thousand dollars an acre because i think
i can earn 60 an acre on it if corn
sells and such and such and soybean
cells and such and such and yield as
such and such and you'd figure it out
that's the same reason you buy
businesses and when you buy stocks
you're buying a little piece of a
business
and that's probably the most important
thing to remember in in investing is
that when you're buying a stock you're
buying a little piece of the business
and
if you are buying it at an attractive
price for the business for the whole
business you're going to make money and
if you aren't
you know over time you won't make money
rule number three don't make decisions
based on opinions charlie munger and i
have been making stock decisions and
business decisions
one way or another together now for 55
years
we have never
let
well the macro doesn't enter into it not
just political we haven't we have not
made decisions differently because one
party or the other's in power we have
not not made decisions based on whether
we thought interest rates were going to
go up or down or or you know what was
going to happen with labor negotiations
someplace
you know you don't want to give up what
you know how to do
because of the opinions which you don't
know whether right or not and which are
going to be transitory in any event so
you really go out there every day
and do whatever makes the most sense so
when we buy the auto dealerships last
week
we don't factor in anything
about the fed about the deadlock and
politics about what's going on around
the world those are all important things
but they don't affect whether those
dealerships which we're buying to own a
hundred years they don't affect whether
they're going to make money in the year
2024 or 2034 or 2044. and the important
thing is whether we get a good business
with good management at a sensible price
rule number four have the right approach
it's very important to have the right
framework you need
you need
you need to have an approach to
investing that sound and
graham's approach is is simple
uh
but some people
uh
adopt to it and and
which i did immediately and and most
people don't
but if you have the right philosophy
you will find opportunities
uh as you go through the next 20 30 40
50 years also if you want to have more
self confidence and self belief i've
designed a special free training to help
you do it the science says it can take
up to 254 days of consecutive action to
build a new habit and i want that for
you i want you to build the habit of
self belief so what i'm going to do is
email you every day for 254 days a link
to an unlisted video that will shift
your belief forward to get on it for
free the link to join is in the
description below
investing in yourself is the best thing
you can do anything that improves your
own talents like nobody can take it away
from me they can run up huge deficits
and the dollar can become worth far less
you can have all kinds of things happen
it's important to associate with people
that are better than yourself they made
us all these crazy things to get out of
ourselves and so we stood on tables and
did all kinds of things rule number five
follow your passion i would follow my
passion i mean whatever turned you on
you know i uh
uh i found i was lucky i found something
early that that turned me on but but uh
you don't want to take a job just for
the money you don't want to take a job
for an organization that you really
don't feel good about or work for people
that you don't feel good about you you
really want to be excited when you get
out of bed every morning and it won't
necessarily be the job that you have 10
years later
but you'll be learning so much as you go
along and
you know i i took a job with ben graham
my hero and and it you know i never
asked the salary and i found at the end
of the month when i got my first
paycheck what i was earning because i
just knew it was the right thing to be
to be doing so i would i would i would
follow
follow your passion rule number six
prepare i think there i think you'll
learn more about yourself
uh if you do it that way i bought my
first stock when i was 11. i was
actually i was at rose hill at the time
and i bought three shares of city
service preferred
at uh 38 and it went down to 27 which is
something i still remember even though i
was 11 at the time
uh and then it went up to 40 and i sold
it i made five bucks on my three shares
after commissions and then it went to
200 and something so
uh you know i i probably remember that a
little better than if i'd been doing it
on paper
and
i fooled around doing a lot of things
between about age 11 and 19 in the stock
market i did charts i did all kinds of
technical analysis i read every book i
could get on the subject
and
i didn't do that well i didn't do
terrible but but i did i was really just
floundering around
but by
that meant by the age of 19 when i read
ben graham's book i was at the
university of nebraska in lincoln i went
and bought this book called the
intelligent investor just come out and
it had an enormous impact on me
now if i hadn't done
in the previous eight years if i hadn't
been all over the lot i'm not so sure
that that book would have had the same
impact on me i mean i was by that time i
was prepared
to read ben graham's book which changed
my life financially in an incredible way
i mean
i wouldn't be up here today if i had
read that book but yeah
part of life is getting prepared
so that
when something does happen that's
significant
you can grasp the significance of it and
know what to do with it and i would say
that first eight years of fooling around
even though it produced nothing
financially to speak of
uh produced a lot in terms of getting my
mind prepared for when i really did read
something that made sense so i was ready
to accept it and i actually went back
and
went to columbia to study under the
undergram and
uh
because of
of reading that book and all kinds of
things flowed out of it so rule number
seven recognize mistakes quickly there
are lots of lousy businesses you know
and there's lots of wonderful businesses
and
my job over the years has been to try
and figure out which is which and i've
made plenty of mistakes i bought a
company called dexter shoes
in the early 90s i paid 400 plus million
dollars for it
and
it it made a lot of money before i
bought it but you know as soon as i
bought it they pulled some switch or
something and it
immediately started losing money and
and it was because of foreign
competition so on there it was maybe
because i owned it i don't know uh
and it went to zero and
the worst thing was
that i paid for it in stock so that 400
million in stock i gave at the time
is uh
now worth about 5 billion so it uh
so uh every time berkshire stock goes
down i feel a little bit better because
of my opportunity
loss on this business but you know when
i looked at dexter shoe they had a good
position in retailers they turned out
good shoes they had a great workforce
all kinds of things but i just forgot
one thing that that they weren't going
to make shoes in the united states
anymore
so you make you make mistakes and it
does pay
to recognize quickly when you've made
them if you've got a good person running
a business and it isn't making any money
uh
you know you're in the wrong business
and and you've got to face up to that
rule number eight have the right
temperament stocks
sell at silly prices from time to time
most stocks at one time or another sell
at very silly prices
and
it doesn't take a high iq to figure out
that they're cheap but it does take a
temperament that's willing to step up
and actually act
i tell people if they're going in the
investment business
if you've got 160 iq
sell 30 points to somebody else because
you won't need it i mean that
it
yeah i mean i figured out very early you
don't have to be that smart of this
business which is fortunate but you do
have to have the right temperament and
you have to be able to ignore
what other people are saying and and
simply look at the facts and decide
is this stock which is selling it x
worth 2x and occasionally you'll find
things like that and if when you don't
find them you don't do anything so
that's my
generalized stock stockton no names
rule number nine don't dwell on mistakes
the worst investment i ever made
how long do you have
[Applause]
well i i've made some very bad ones but
that doesn't really bother me i i you
know it may bother the shareholders but
that's another question
the uh
you know you're going to make you're
going to make mistakes in life i mean
there's no question about it you don't
want to make them on the big decisions
you know who you marry and says and
things like that so there's no way i'm
going to make a lot of business and
investment decisions without making some
mistakes i may try to minimize them
i i don't i don't dwell on them at all i
don't i don't look back the biggest
mistakes
are the ones that actually don't show up
they're the mistakes of omission rather
than commission we've never lost that
much money
on any one investment uh
uh but it's the things that i knew
enough to do that i didn't do we have we
have missed profits
of as much as you know maybe 10 billion
dollars in things
that i knew enough to do and i didn't do
now the fact i didn't buy microsoft way
back
uh is not a foregone opportunity because
i didn't know enough to make that
decision but there have been other
investments where i didn't know enough
to make the decision
and for one reason or another i either
didn't do it at all or i did it on a
small scale i was sucking my thumb when
i should have been writing checks you
know basically
and and
you know those don't show up
there's no place where it shows missed
opportunities but i've i've missed some
big ones the triumphs in life
are are partly triumphs because you know
that everything isn't going to be a
triumph and and
i would never get too hung up
on mistakes i know a lot of people that
really agonize over them and and it it
just isn't worth it i mean tomorrow's
another day and you live it forward and
just go on to the next thing and rule
number 10 the last one before some very
special bonus clips
is have fun you haven't had any security
problems i don't think mercury's got had
any security problems how about didn't
your wife lose her credit card want your
first wife lose her credit card once
oh yeah oh yeah
when my first wife lost her credit card
i made no attempt to get it back because
the guy was spending less than she was
now i've got some special bonus clips
that i think you're going to enjoy but
before that it's time for the question
of the day i want to know what was your
single biggest takeaway from this video
and your plan of action for the next
week when you just watch a video and you
get motivated the sign says you have a
35 chance of actually following through
that's not good enough believe nation we
need to take some action but when you
watch a video you get motivated and you
create a specific plan of action that
number jumps from 35 percent to 91
chance of you following through and when
you publicly commit to other people like
leaving a comment down in this video
your number jumps to 95 percent change
of you actually following through on the
plan you set for yourself so i want to
know your single biggest takeaway from
this video and your plan of action for
the next week leave it down in the
comments below so i can celebrate you
i would encourage you if you're
interested in the field to do a few
things i still try and make it as
intelligent as possible i would try to
stick with things businesses i thought i
understood i'd still get out that sheet
of paper and i'd write i'm doing this
because
and just test my reasoning then i go
back and read it a year later and and
see whether what you thought would be
true turned out to be true so i would
always check myself i believe in grading
myself on everything you know doctors
have post-mortems and they they do it
because they learn from postmortems uh
in business people don't like to do
postmortems when i'm i'm i can be on the
board of a company and they never wanted
two years later to run a check on how
that decision turned out because it it
can be unpleasant
uh but you learn from postmortems and
you don't want to learn it's way better
to learn from other people's mistakes
than your own but you got to learn from
a few of your own too and
the time to do it is when you're young
the allowance when i was a little boy
was a nickel a week but i like the idea
of
having a little more than a nickel a
week to work with and i went into
business very early
i started selling coca-cola door-to-door
i sold gum door-to-door or sold saturday
ink post liberty magazine ladies home
journal you name it
[Music]
i think i enjoyed the game almost right
from the start
but i like being my own boss
that's one thing i like about delivering
papers
i could arrange the route i wanted
nobody was bothering me at five or six
in the morning
i was delivering 500 papers a day and i
made a penny of paper but in terms of
compounding
that penny shirt into something else
people ask me what they should take in
business school and and and uh
or even if they don't go to business
school what they need to know before
getting in business and i tell them you
know you have to
you have to understand accounting it's
the language i mean it would be it's
like being in a foreign country without
knowing the language if you're in
business and you don't understand
accounting so it it
you you want to get as comfortable with
that
uh as you are with the english language
it
it's made me
a lot of money because i
i listened to what ray dean had to say
53 or 4 years ago
and have been able to understand
uh
what
i was seeing on pieces of paper what
that told me about businesses and the
limitations of what it told me about
businesses i mean i henry ford as you
may know
failed twice before he started the
ford motor company in 1903 i mean
the
the test
isn't whether you get the greatest
business idea in the world the first
time out the test is whether you keep
learning as you go along
what your strengths are and what you can
do for your customers what you can bring
especially to the party
you need
a
genuine
a genuine desire day and
day out
to
delight the customer
i've never i've never seen a business
and i've seen
a lot of businesses but i've never seen
one that
delights the customer
that
that doesn't succeed i mean what you
want is that customer the next day when
they think do i want to rent a car or do
i want to buy some furniture
what goes through their mind
you know it's the place where they've
had a great experience
i don't know what
i paid for this
type actually probably if somebody gave
it to me but for the purposes of the
speech i will
say i i have no idea but what i or the
shirt i'm wearing others but i do know i
will remember
how i was treated
when i bought it i mean you long forget
about
the price
but you never forget
whether you had a good experience or a
poor experience
uh with the purchase experience and i
don't need to be
in washington to figure out what the
washington post
uh newspaper is worth and i don't need
to be in new york to figure out what
some other company is worth it's it's
it's simply it's an intellectual process
and the less the less static there is in
that intellectual process really the
better off you are what is the
intellectual process intellectual
processes
is
defining your level defining your area
of competence and valuing businesses
and then
within that area of competence finding
whatever sells at the at the cheapest
price in relation to value and there are
all kinds of things i'm not competent to
value but there are a few that i am
confident
have you ever bought a technology
company no i really haven't
in 30 years of investing not one i
haven't understood any of them so you
haven't ever owned for example ibm never
owned ibm marvelous company i mean a
sensational company but i haven't owned
ibm
and so here is this technological
revolution going on and you're not going
to be a participant going right past me
is that all right with you it's okay
with me
i don't have i don't have to make money
in every game i mean i don't know what
cocoa beans are going to do
i don't you know there are all kinds of
things i don't know about and that may
be too bad but
you know why should i know all about
them i haven't worked that hard on them
in securities business
you literally every day have thousands
of the major american corporations
offered you
at a price and a price that changes
daily
and you don't have to make any decisions
you have to make
nothing is forced upon you so you there
are no called strikes in the business
the pitcher just stands there and throws
balls at you
and uh if you're playing real baseball
and it's between the knees and the
shoulders you either swing or you got a
strike call on you if you get too many
call i know you're out in the securities
business
you sit there and they throw
us steel at 25 and they throw general
motors at 68 and you don't have to swing
at any of them they may be wonderful
pitches to swing at but if you don't
know enough you don't have to swing
and you can sit there and watch
thousands of pitches and finally get one
right there where you want it something
that you understand and then you swing
i've got this rule you know the first
rule is don't lose in the second rule is
never forget the first rule so it really
isn't so much having a lot of brilliant
decisions it's just not really having
some terrible ones and and and frankly i
did learn from ben graham how to avoid
ever having any disasters and
investments
it wasn't that you were going to come up
with the very smartest thing but if you
never have any any significant losses
you know some singles and doubles will
produce a lot of runs before you get
through leadership at berkshire
really consists
of
taking a bunch of people
who in a baseball uh
analogy would be 400 hitters
and just handing them the bat and just
telling them to get up their plate and
take a big swing
there's very little to it beyond that
one thing i do
is i send them a letter the only thing i
tell them
and this letter which went out january
20th 2003 it says it's been two and a
half years since my last memo now how
many big companies have you have the
managers out there been two and a half
years since they've heard from the home
office been two and a half years since
my last
memo
here are a couple things to keep in mind
and number one
and this is number one every time this
doesn't change it won't change two years
from now or four years from now or six
years
number one we can afford to lose money
even a lot of money
we cannot afford to lose reputation even
a shred of reputation
let's be sure that everything we do in
business can be be reported on the front
page of a national newspaper
in an article written by an unfriendly
but intelligent reporter
in many areas including acquisitions
berkshire's results have benefited from
its reputation and we don't want to do
anything that in any way can tarnish it
last year berkshire was ranked by
fortune as the fourth most admired
company in the world this year we were
third in the united states they just
published it
it took us 37 years to get there but we
could lose it in 37 minutes
and that's the message i mean we
you know we we can lose money it does
you know
nicer to make money but we've got
we'll figure out ways to make money
but we can't lose we can't lose a
shredder reputation
because you don't get it back if you
look around you at the people you admire
you know they have certain qualities i
mean you've got you've got friends why
do you like them you know
generally
you know that they
generally they have an upbeat attitude
on life generally they're generous
people they're humorous people they're
people that do more than their share
they're people that are thinking about
something nice they can do for you and
all those qualities attract you
and none of those are
are innate at birth i mean you you can
acquire those and then there's other
people that turn you off you know and
and uh
they have habits they take credit for
things they didn't do they don't show up
on time whatever it may be they're a
little dishonest about things
and
if you're looking at your life at a
young age like you are and you can
choose what kind of a person you can be
why not be the person you admire rather
than the person you can't stand it's so
simple so just write down
the qualities you like take your take
your five best friends why do you like
them and just write down those qualities
and you will find there's no quality
there that you
can't have yourself and similarly with
the five people you can't stand to be
around
but those put those things down to turn
you off about those people and
if they turn you off about them why
should you possess them you're gonna
it's it's so simple uh
you know it's it's not
it's not it's not like some something
complicated you think you should be
learning you know whether it's
investing in the stock market no but
it's it's enormously important to have
people work with you in life right
they're going to work with you in life
if they like you you know and they may
occasionally i mean if you're in the
army or something you know you may work
for somebody that you don't like but by
and large
you're going to get the best out of
people if they feel good about you
and
it's just so easy but you've got to
develop the habits early because you
can't say i'm going to suddenly become a
terribly attractive person when i'm 60.
it just doesn't work that way
so pick up the right habits now
and
i will guarantee you if you actually
just write down those qualities
and think about it you will find you can
have every one of the attractive
qualities get rid of the ones that are
negative
and your life will be different
i like to read more than most kids i
really like to read a lot
my auntie gave me a copy of the world
almanac and that was heaven to me and i
can still tell you that almost
population was 214 0006 in 1930.
some numbers just kind of stick with you
and very early probably when i was seven
or so i took this book out of the benson
library called a thousand ways to make a
thousand dollars
and one of the ways in this book was
having penny weighing machines
and i sat and calculated how much it
would cost to buy the first weighing
machine and how long it would take for
the profit for that one to buy another
one i would sit there and create these
compound interest tables to figure out
how long it would take me to have a
weighing machine for every person in the
world first books i read on investment
were actually in my dad's office
pretty soon i read all the books in the
office and read some of them more than
once
a few years ago i went to amazon
and sure enough they had this manual
there so
while reliving my youth other guys were
going to amazon probably and
buying old playboys or something but i
bought old movies manuals instead and
when i got out of school i started
selling stocks i was 20 years old at the
time and looked about 16 and acted about
12 so i was not the most impressive
sales person anybody ever met
but what i would do was i i went through
page by page
looking for
possibly undervalued stocks yeah well
i've made a lot of mistakes biggest
mistake
well not the biggest necessarily the
biggest but but buying berkshire
hathaway itself was a mistake because
berkshire was a lousy textile business
and i brought it very cheap
i've been taught
by ben graham
to buy things on a quantitative basis
look around for things that are cheap
and
that i was taught that we'll say in 1949
or they made a big impression on me so i
went around looking for what
i call
used cigar butts of stocks
and the cigar but approach to buying
stocks is that you walk down the street
and you're looking around for cigar
butts and you find this obviously this
terrible looking soggy ugly
looking cigar
one puff left in it but you pick it up
and you get your one puff disgusting you
throw it away but it's free i mean it's
cheap and then you look around for
another soggy you know one puff
cigarette well that's what i did for
years
it's a mistake uh although you make
money doing it but you can't make it
with big money it's so much easier just
to buy wonderful businesses so now i
would rather buy a wonderful business at
a fair price than a fair business at a
wonderful price but in those days i was
buying cheap stocks and berkshire was
selling below its working capital per
share you got the plants for nothing you
got the machinery for nothing you got
the inventory and receivables at the
discount it was cheap
so i bought it
and
20 years later i was still running a
lousy business and that money did not
compound
you really want to be in a wonderful
business because the time is the friend
of the wonderful business you keep
compounding it keeps doing more business
and you keep making more money
time is the enemy of the lousy business
i could have sold berkshire perhaps
liquidated it and made a quick little
profit you know one puff
but staying with those kind of
businesses is is a big mistake so you
might say i learned
something out of
that mistake and i would have been way
better off taking
what i did with berkshire is i kept
buying better businesses i started
insurance business sees candy the
buffalo all kinds of things i would have
been way better doing that with a
with a brand new little entity that i'd
set up
rather than using berkshire as the
platform now i've had a lot of fun out
of it i mean everything in life seems to
turn out for the better so i i don't
have any complaints about that but it
was a dumb thing to do
i went in the u.s air
i bought a preferred stock in 1989
as soon as my check cleared
the company went into the red and never
got out i mean it was a
really dumb i mean
i've got an 800 number i call now
whenever i think about buying an airline
stock i call them up any hour that
fortunately i can call them at three in
the morning and i just dial and i say my
name's warren i'm an aeroholic you know
and i'm thinking about buying this thing
and they talk me down i mean things
takes takes hours sometimes but it's
worth it believe me uh if you ever think
about that buying an airline stock call
me and i'll give you the 800 number
because
you don't want to do it
but
we got lucky in terms of how we
eventually came out on it but it was a
dumb dumb decision if you tell me who
your heroes are i can tell you how
you're going to turn out to quite an
extent
by this point in life and i i i have
been extraordinarily lucky
and that none of my heroes ever let me
down i mean the ones i
came up with
uh throughout their lives uh i've never
felt that i've been let down in any way
with it number one was my dad and and
and uh
uh had a huge impression on me
um my wife who is heroes is one of my
heroes i mean she is
you know in terms of of she's taught me
a tremendous amount and then and
never seen anybody any better with human
beings than
she is and
uh you can you know yogi bear again said
you can you can observe a lot just by
watching and uh
i uh you know i i watched my dad and
i've watched her and
uh i had a
professor ben graham uh back at columbia
and had a huge impact on me so i have
been lucky in that i've had
terrific heroes and they they haven't
let me down and and uh
that
that takes you a long long way i've gone
through one or two periods where we're
kind of tough in life but
not any i mean everybody's had had that
but but having the right heroes will
take you right through it if you buy a
business if you buy a farm you know you
go up and look
you know every couple weeks to see how
far the corn is up and you know you
worry too much about whether somebody
says this is going to be a year of low
prices because exports are being
affected or anything like that you know
you buy a farm and you hold it for i've
got one farm that i bought in the 1980s
and my son runs it but
i've been there once you know i mean it
it it doesn't grow faster if i go and
stare at it you know i can't cheer for
it you know more effort more effort or
something like that and i know there's
going to be some years when prices are
going to be good and some when the
prices aren't going to be good i know
there's years when yields will be better
than others
what about the farm and and uh
if
it just doesn't i don't care about
economic predictions on anything of the
sort i do care that over
over the years it's well tended to in
terms of rotating crops and i hope
yields get better which they generally
have
in fact
that farm
100 years ago would have probably
produced
30 bushels maybe 35 bushels of corn per
acre
now in a good year you know it'd be 200
i mean
we really made progress in this country
that's one reason commodity prices go
back a couple hundred years they've
moved so little is because we've just
gotten better and better
whether it's
cotton or whether it's it's corn or soy
beans or
all kinds of things
and you and i have benefited from that
and so apple's kind of like a farm
well it's it's a it's a long term
investment and and
if you owned
if you owned the the best auto
dealership in town uh the best brand and
you had
somebody
good running you wouldn't drop by every
day and say you know how many people
have come in today or you know i think
interest rates are going up a little
maybe that'll slow down our sales or
anything no
you buy it knowing there's 365 days a
year and you're going to own it for 20
years so that's 7 300 days and you know
they're gonna things are going to be
different from day to day and year to
year you shouldn't buy it at the
day-to-day stuff is important well
speaking of resources let's talk a
little bit about your
decision to put your money with uh bill
and melinda gates uh you are somebody
obviously who's
you know arguably not even arguably
definitively by numbers the best in the
world in terms of figuring out how to
allocate capital i mean dollars don't
lie and then put it to work and yet with
philanthropy
you out you basically outsourced it how
did that well that's true but you know
when my wife had a
a baby i didn't deliver it either i mean
i you know
i i didn't fill my kids teeth i mean you
know i
adam smith in 1776 explained
specialization of labor he did a pretty
good job of that and i feel i'm very
good at at
piling up money and and my wife was very
good at unpiling it i mean it's a very
simple formula and she was going to
handle
the philanthropy big time and and she
did during her lifetime at a at a
moderate level but basically i was going
to turn it all over to her to handle and
i would pile up during my lifetime and
and she died bef you know earlier and
and therefore i had to make a decision
as to what was the best way to use a
very large sum of money
uh and and get my
goals achieved through other people and
uh there are other people that are
better than i am and all kinds of things
i mean
a-rod's here i mean you know we're not
going to get into a home run derby
so i believe in i believe in
i i really do believe in getting people
that are younger more energetic but also
experienced
and in the case of bill and melinda have
their own money up as well and they've
got similar they've got identical
objectives really with me and if i can
get them to do the work and i can keep
having fun doing what i do i'll do it
and it's getting the game like sure
i bought the first shares of berkshire
in 1962 and it was a northern textile
business destined to become extinct
eventually and
it was a
statistically cheap stock in a terrible
business
berkshire hathaway was closing mills and
as they closed mills it would free up
some capital and then they would
repurchase shares so i bought some stock
with the idea that there would be
another tender offer at some point and
we would sell the stock at a modest
profit
and at one point
the management asked me at what price we
would tender our stock and i said 11 and
50 cents
and the tender offer came out a few
months later
and uh
it was at 11 and 3
was an eighth of a point cheaper
and that made me very mad so i just
started buying more stock
i just felt that i had been
double-crossed by the management and
in may of 1965 but bought enough so we
control the company one of the reasons
warren's successful is he's brutal in
appraising his own past he wants to
identify miss thinkings and avoid them
in the future
but it was an accident that he chose
berkshire hathaway if the chairman
hadn't tried to cheat him out of an
eighth there wouldn't have been any
buffet dash berkshire hathaway history
if you're emotional about investment
you're not going to do well
you may have all these feelings about
the stock the stock has no feelings
about you
looking back it's interesting that
tender offer i didn't realize it but it
happened about five days after my dad
had died and whether that affected me or
not i don't know
well i was lucky that i got started
early i mean always helps if you get
started early and
and my dad happened to be in investment
business so i would go down his office
on
saturdays and so at age probably seven
or something i started reading these
books that were around the place and
so i had a
15-year jump on many people in a sense
and that that helped a lot and and i was
always fascinated by them i knew what i
wanted to do early and i think that's a
that's a huge advantage too
and then you don't need you don't need a
lot of brains in this business i mean
i've always said if you got an iq of 160
give away 30 points to somebody else
because you don't need it in investments
what you do need is emotional stability
you have to
you have to be able to think
independently and you have to be you
have to be when you come to a conclusion
you have to really not care what other
people say and and just follow the facts
and follow your reasoning and and that's
that's tough for a lot of people that
that part i think i was just lucky with
i was born that way
in terms of emotions it's uh truism that
investing emotions are your enemy
absolutely that uh when the market's
good if you feel good don't if you feel
bad you should probably do it right
but how how did you uh what was that
extra thing where uh so many will
acknowledge that and yet we saw in the
current crisis they they panicked why
you went into seemingly uh potential
disasters like ge and goldman sachs
i can't really tell you the i mean i
didn't learn in school or anything i
just it never bothered me if people
disagreed with what i thought
as long as i felt i knew the facts i
mean there's a whole bunch of things i
don't know think about i just stay away
from those so i stay within what i call
my circle of confidence you know that
tom watson said it best he said you know
he said he said i'm no genius but i'm
smart in spots and i stay around those
spots well i try and stay around those
spots and i
i just don't have a a problem if if
somebody says you know you're wrong on
something i just i go back and look at
the facts and and
i think that
i think that really is much more
important frankly than having a few
points of iq or or having an extra
course or two in in school or anything
of the sort you need emotional stability
by far the best investment you can make
is in yourself i mean that for example
communication skills i tell the students
that come that
they're going to
graduate schools and
business and they're learning all these
complicated formulas and all that if
they just learn to communicate better
and both in writing and in person they
increase their value at least 50 percent
no i mean
if you can't communicate somebody who
says you know it's like winking at a
girl in the dark nothing happens you
know basically and and you have to be
able to get
get both your ideas and uh
and that's
that's relatively easy i did it myself
with the dale carnegie of course some
people wish i'd taken a shorter course
now in terms of my talking later on but
it
it's just hugely important and you if
you invest in yourself nobody can take
it away from you well i look at a lot of
figures just in connection with our
businesses i i uh
i like to get numbers so so i i'm
getting reports in
weekly in some businesses uh uh that but
that doesn't tell me what the economy's
gonna do six months from now or three
months from now it tells me what's going
on now with our businesses uh
and
it really doesn't make any difference in
what i do today in terms of buying
stocks or buying businesses what those
numbers tell me they're interesting but
they're not they're not guides to me
because if if we buy business we're
going to hold it forever so we're going
to have good years bad years in between
years maybe a disastrous year or
something here and and
uh
we care a lot about the price we do not
care about the next 12 months economic
predictions just don't enter into our
decisions charlie munger my partner and
i
in
you know 54 years now
we've never made a decision based on an
economic prediction we make business
predictions about what individual
businesses will do over time
and we compare that to what we have to
pay for
but we have never said yes
to something because we thought the
economy was going to do well in the next
year or two years and we've never said
no to anything
because we're right in the middle of a
panic even if the price was right you
know how do you turn failure into a plus
uh and it's true when i was at the
university of nebraska
one day i was reading the daily
nebraskan
and it said
in room
300 or something
at 3 o'clock there will be this panel of
three
professors here at the university and
they're going to award the nathan gold
scholarship i don't know whether you
still you still have that around
and at the time
uh it said it would give you 500 to go
to the graduate school of your choice i
don't know whether it's change in the
amount but but that that was it so i
read this
and i went there to this room at three
o'clock that day or whatever it was
and i walked in the room
and there were the professors
and i was the only student that showed
up i mean it really got to them i mean
they were stuck they you know they kept
waiting and looking at their watch and
hoping there would be more candidates
but there no one came in so
i won 500 by by default and
those are usually my biggest triumphs
when nobody else shows up
and so here i was i had 500
to go toward
any it wasn't it wasn't limited as any
any graduate school for a master's
degree so i applied to harvard my dad
wanted me to
uh
i shortly heard from harvard
and they said go to chicago and meet
this fellow running
that who interviews applicants from the
midwest
so i got on the train and that's what
you did in those days and i spent about
10 hours on the burlington
going to chicago
then i transferred to another little
inner urban train to go up to this
country day school where this fellow was
the headmaster and he was the big
interviewer for harvard
and i got there and after about
10 minutes he
he said
better think about something else that
uh you know he uh come back later on i
was i was 19 at the time and
uh
i looked about 12 you know and and i and
i acted about eight so
it was not a great combination uh but so
he he said forget it
so i spent uh took the little interurban
train back to chicago and i took the
10-hour train back to oman all the time
you know what do i tell my parents you
know it's kind of embarrassing
uh but
it was it was the luckiest thing ever
happened to me i
because
if i'd gone to harvard i would have gone
to a two-year
business school
i i i instead applied to columbia where
i could graduate in one year and get a
master's degree
luckily
that by the accident of it and being in
the nebraska national guard which did
not get called up for the korean war
i missed
going in the korean war
i
i got to meet ben graham and which had
an enormous effect on me subsequently
and i probably got my wife that way
because she was going to northwestern
and i was able to put on sort of a full
court press because i got out in one
year and otherwise
she'd she'd have met some other guy i
mean i i got her before the competition
showed up and
uh
so it worked out wonderfully it couldn't
have worked out better
and
that's been that's been my life
basically i mean it the things
you know you will get some
disappointments you know
uh
but if i knew every decision i was going
to make was going to be perfect it would
not be as much fun be like playing golf
and knowing you're going to hit a hole
in one on every hole you wouldn't play
golf if every time you got on a tee
you just took a swing and the ball ended
up in the hole you know be fun for a few
days you get on tv
but it the game would not be any fun uh
so it's
failure you know
and i wouldn't even consider them
failures but they're mistakes or
whatever you want to call it they're
they're part of the game and
in the end you know you go on and and
we've made plenty of mistakes in
business we'll make plenty more
and then you know the
babe ruth and you know for a long time
it subsequently got eclipsed by
a few fellows but uh he held the record
for strikeouts you know also the of the
record for home runs and was the highest
baseball player until
the modern era came along uh so it's
it's part of the game if you take big
swings you know you
you may you may you're going to miss
sometimes i would like to tell you of
two women
uh
that
each sold a business
to berkshire hathaway
uh to me actually for many many many
millions of dollars
both of them started with 2500
by a coincidence was the exact same
amount it was everything they had in the
world
and one of them
was a woman
who landed in seattle in 1917
couldn't speak a word of english
had a tag around her neck
the tag said
fort dodge iowa
the red cross
got her to fort dodge where she was
reunited with her husband who had come
to the country a couple of years earlier
and she lived in fort dodge for two
years
and as she put it
she felt like a dummy
she couldn't pick up the language she
couldn't learn a word
and so she decided she and her husband
decided
to move to omaha
so they came to omaha
in 1919
and there she found a
small colony of russian jews so she
started feeling more at home
and then as her oldest daughter went to
school
she would come home this daughter
francis
and she would teach her mother the words
she learned in school that day
and this woman rose bumpkin
spent 20 years
saving money
bringing first her siblings over
her mother and father
fifty dollars at a time she sold used
clothing to do it
she had four children during this period
and by 1937 after 20 years
she'd save twenty five hundred dollars
she went to chicago
and she bought what she could have
furniture her dream had always been to
open
a furniture store
and this woman
who had never gone to school one day in
her life
with 2 500
but with the same spirit that the people
in this room had
about having a dream
and working to accomplish that dream
she built a business
which she sold to me
in 1983 for
60 million dollars approximately in
which
which did a billion and a half dollars
worth of business last year
the fourth generation is working in that
business
this woman rose blumpkin
lived
well she she worked for me until she was
103. and
then i'm not saying then she retired and
she died the next year which is a lesson
to all of berkshire's managers that
premature retirement you know nothing
you can't tell what's going to happen
but mrs b
with her twenty five hundred dollars
one further fact about her
she could not read or write
and she went into a furniture business
and she didn't bring anything in unique
in furniture but she brought a
determination to succeed
she knew she could outwork anyone else
she knew she cared about her customers
she worked at very low gross margins but
she built this incredible business
what do you consider the most important
quality for an investment manager
it's a temperamental quality not an
intellectual quality you don't need tons
of iq in this business i mean you have
to have enough iq to get from here to
downtown omaha but
but
you do not have to be able to play
three-dimensional chess or be in the top
leagues in terms of bridge playing or
something of sort you need
a stable
personality you need a temperament
that neither derives great pleasure from
being with the crowd or against the
crowd because this is not a business
where you take polls it's a business
where you think
and ben graham would say that you're not
right or wrong because a thousand people
agree with you
and you're not right or wrong because a
thousand people disagree with you you're
right because your facts and your
reasoning are right how do you know when
to throw in the towel on an investment
or a business
i want to throw in the title on an
investment or a business business yeah
well you what you know you you're doing
too late
i've done i i went in the textile
business by accident
in
1965
and i threw in the towel about 20 years
later
and that was about 20 years too late
the there's a great tendency to want to
uh
hold on justify old decisions i mean
that's a human human trait and
uh
what when you really know you've got a
bad business is when you have a good
manager and you're getting bad results i
mean it when you when you're when you're
getting bad results with a bad manager
you still have to
examine the question of whether you know
you can get better results if you get a
better manager usually you can't you
know i've said in the past you know that
when a
when a
management with a reputation
for excellence
encounters a business with a reputation
for bad economics it's the reputation of
the business that remains intact and and
i've proved that many times uh
there are businesses that are just plain
tough you know and there's the con
there may be too many competitors but
there's reasons why they don't drop out
there's reasons well we we started out
in textiles and we made over half of the
uh the linings for men's suits in the
country and we
we went through world war ii and got
awards and and sears roebuck named us
their
supplier of the year and all of that
sort of thing
and uh then we'd say well we'd like to
increase the price of
of these linings a quarter of a cent a
yard and seriously we gotta be reminders
and other guys that'll sell it to us at
the old price and
nobody ever went into a sears store and
said i'd like a blue surge shirt a blue
shirt surge suit
with a half away lining you know
it didn't exist we had no
connection to the consumer and
there are lots of lousy businesses you
know and there's lots of wonderful
businesses
and
my job over the years has been to try
and figure out which is which and i've
made plenty of mistakes i bought a
company called texture shoes
in the early 90s i paid 400 plus million
dollars for it and
it it made a lot of money before i
bought it but you know as soon as i
bought it they pulled some switch or
something and it
immediately started losing money and uh
and it was because of foreign
competition so on there it was maybe
because i owned it i don't know uh
and it went to zero and
the worst thing was
that i paid for it in stock so that 400
million in stock i gave at the time
is uh
now worth about 5 billion so it
so
every time berkshire stock goes down i
feel a little bit better because of my
opportunity
loss on this business but you know when
i looked at dexter's shoe they had a
good position in retailers they turned
out good shoes they had a great
workforce all kinds of things but i just
forgot one thing that that they weren't
going to make shoes in the united states
anymore
so you make you make mistakes and it
does pay
to recognize
quickly when you've made them if you've
got a good person running a business and
it isn't making any money
uh
you know you're in the wrong business
and and you've got to face up to that
when you get to my age you will not
measure
how well you've done by how much money
you've got i can guarantee you that
you'll all do fine on money anyway i
mean uh you know think about it seven
hours a day
you know
you're in a bed you've got exactly the
same mattress i've got if you don't
whistle it two at the furniture mark you
know i mean so so that when we're on a
parody i can't i can't outdo you you
know in terms of my sleeping enjoyment
you can you can match it by by buying
this mattress which we'll give you a
special price on just mention my name
we eat at the same places you know we
eat a dairy queen particularly if you're
in my position because we own it but but
we eat at mcdonald's and burger king and
and when i leave here i'll stop by a
fast food place i mean i had a 10 year
old car up till about a year ago you
know and it just doesn't make any
difference to me and they they all work
we live in a place that's warm in the
winter and it's cool in the summer and
we watch the super bowl on big screen tv
you do it i do it you know we dress more
or less the same i mean i pay more for
my clothes but they look cheap when i
put them on so we're really
we're on a parody yeah so so the money
isn't going to be that big a deal
everybody in this country is going to
you know that with the intelligence this
group has the energy you have you're
going to do well
so what's the difference you know what
really counts
well i would say
that you will measure health is
enormously important and that's a matter
of a fair amount of luck i mean you know
so i won't i don't want i'm not
shortchanging it i'm just saying you
can't do too much about that but
you will measure your success in life
by whether by how many
and extent whether it's the people you
want
at 70 or whatever the age may be
you'll measure by how many of them
really love you you know in the end i
mean you can't
you know you you can't buy love i mean
it doesn't work you buy sex you can buy
testimonial dinners you can buy your
name on buildings you can do all kinds
of things
but the you know the only way you get to
be you know love is to be lovable it's
kind of irritating actually you've got a
lot of money it'd be more fun to just
write out a check for a million dollars
so everybody you know from now on loves
me but it doesn't work that way and in
fact
it the only way is to be is to be
lovable and and you know i've got this
friend
who uh
who came out of auschwitz
and had at least one member of the
family die there
and
what is it now it's uh
60 years later
you know she still
when she looks at people it's a polish
jew when she looks at people
the question she asks herself
in determining who she really trusts his
friends
the one question in her mind is would
they hide me
now when you get to be 70
if you've got a lot of people that would
hide you
you've had a successful life
i know people who have a tremendous
amount of money no one would hide their
own kids wouldn't hide them i mean they
they really wouldn't i mean their
business associates wouldn't or anybody
else if it really came down to it
you know
they they don't have anybody's respect
they've got their attention maybe with
money or something that sort but they
they nobody loves them and
uh my friend tom murphy at campus cities
tv i mean dozens of people would hide
murph you know
all kinds of people
would hide my wife you know
that uh ben graham a lot of people would
have my dad it would have had a number
and then like i say that i can i can
tell you people
that
you know everybody
may pay homage to them and the kids may
put up with them and hope they don't
change their will or something but the
truth is that nobody would hide them and
if you've got a lot of people that would
hide you
when you get to be 70
you will have a very successful life
everything you do learn is cumulative i
mean that doesn't mean that
industries stay good forever or
businesses stay good forever but but
learning to think about business models
what i learned at 20 is useful to me now
what i learned at 25 is useful to me now
and so
it's not it's not so it's not a field
that
changes
dramatically in terms of the underlying
principles it's like physics i mean
there's underlying principles now
they're doing all kinds of things with
physics they weren't doing 50 years ago
but
but if you know the if you've got the
principles if you know what makes a good
business if you know what makes a good
manager you know if you know what makes
a a good product
uh
and you learn that in one business you
can there is some transference
to other businesses as you go along and
you learn what things you you're not
going to understand i mean
knowing what to leave out is just as
important as knowing what to focus on
and
uh i don't think i can win every game
you know somebody said how do you beat
bobby fischer you play him any game
except chess so i don't play bobby
fischer chess
and that's there's a lot of value to
learning that over time and and learning
what you're good at and what you're not
good at you know the most important
thing
uh
aside from the things i've talked about
already is it's really who you associate
with you want to associate with people
that are better than you are i mean
basically you'll go in the direction of
the people that you associate with and
and you want to have the right heroes uh
you want people
if you want to emulate somebody you
better pick very carefully who you want
to emulate and
and when
obviously you can't pick your parents uh
they're gonna have an enormous influence
on you but you don't get a choice on
that but you get choices as you go down
the line and you
who you uh
who you admire who you who who you want
to copy and the most important for most
people in terms of that decision is
their spouse it's also important in
terms of a partner in business with the
partner in life is
is the most important one you want to
pick a spouse that's a little that's
better than you are
and then he or she and
you hope they don't figure it out too
fast
all of you in this room
have the brains to do extremely well in
life
you've all got the energy to do
extremely well in life and then the
question is how do you apply it
if you've got a 200 horsepower motor
you get 200 horsepower out of it you get
your full
potential or do you get 100 horsepower
or 50 horsepower
now there's two things that can
hold you back
in getting the full horsepower out of
your your engine whatever it may be all
of you have big enough engines
and one of those is a lack of education
but that probably isn't going to happen
to very many people in this room if you
did have a lack of education if
you didn't have a chance to get a decent
education in life it wouldn't make any
difference what that potential was
because
you'd never unlock it
but the second most important thing
and equally as important
is in terms of the habits that you
develop in terms of what you do with
yourself
when we
hire people we look for three qualities
we look for integrity we look for
intelligence and we look for energy
but if they don't have the first one
integrity the other two will kill you
because if you're hiring somebody
without integrity you really want to be
dumb and lazy don't you i mean you know
last thing in the world you want forms
to be smart and energetic so smart
energetic only goes with integrity you
can't change
your iq or how far you control football
or how high you can jump or the color of
your hair very easily but you can
elect
to have integrity that matches anybody
else's and if you match that with
intelligence which you have and energy
which you have
uh you will get an extraordinary result
and you'd be very foolish to sell me ten
percent of yourself for fifty thousand
on the other hand
if you don't match it with that your
potential will in a significant part go
unused what other habits did you
cultivate in your 20s and your 30s that
you now see as being foundational to
your success as a business person
well i
i knew
a lot
about what i do uh when i was 20. i mean
i i i really read a lot and
i aspired to learn everything that i
could about the subject so
intellectually i knew a lot
i did not know a lot about human
behavior i mean that
that you can't learn really out of
reading books but it's it's very
important to understand people and uh i
say to the students
you know just imagine you could buy
or or you could be given
10 of the future earnings of one person
that you know
among everybody you know now are you
going to pick the person that's the
smartest i'm going to pick the person
that can
dance the best or that can run the
fastest or anything like that that's the
right height no anything no no they're
you're gonna you're gonna
pick the person that has the right
habits that that is cheerful generous
gives other people credit for what they
do you know and when you look at all of
the qualities that you admire in other
people which would cause you to pick
that person say to yourself which of
those qualities can't i have myself
because they are
you know you determine whether you have
them so just write them down on a piece
of paper who is the person that you
admire the most or like the best why do
i like them and just write down and then
say which of these can i do myself and
the truth is you can do them and then
you also if you really want to carry it
to the next extreme you pick the person
you dislike the most and why do you
dislike that person you know and you
know they always
they're never fair about things
basically they always claim more credit
than they're doing everything and write
down those qualities and say if you
dislike that some other person why in
the world would you want to have those
yourself so you should get rid of those
and it's it's a pretty simple thing to
do but you want to be the person that if
you could pick your best friend you know
that you would have the same qualities
i'm 72. i'm getting social security now
so i'm you know i i
i should be in florida you know
pushing shuffleboard around or something
of the sort but but
but i do what i can do anything in the
world i want to do but what i want to do
is run berkshire hathaway now why do i
want to run it that way
a i get to paint my own painting you
know i go down there every day
and i feel like you know i feel like
michelangelo there you know working on
the sistine chapel or something nobody
else may think it's a great painting but
i get to paint my own painting i do not
have people second guessing me
i do not have people saying why don't
you use a little more red paint than
blue paint why don't you paint a
seascape instead of a landscape i get to
do my own thing i get the it's it's it's
a form of creativity it's it's exactly
like
somebody feels it's a professional
golfer or somebody feels it's a painter
they're not doing it for the money
primarily
we've got a company flight safety with
trains more pilots than anybody in the
world
flight safety is run by an 85 year old
man al yoshi al started the company with
ten thousand dollars in 1951
it now trains four or five times as many
pilots as a
non-military pilot as any as anybody in
the world
and he is there at 85 and
it's a matter of public record he's got
a billion dollars worth of berkshire
shares he works seven days a week he
loves it and he loves it for the same
reason that i love what i do he gets to
do it his way
he buys these big simulators that you
trying pilots in he doesn't have to
check with me as to whether to spend 15
million dollars for a simulator he
doesn't ask me he knows so much more
about it than you know that i do why in
the world would he ask me well i can't
tell what kind of a plane i'm in you
know when i'm flying around and and al
is spending a couple hundred million
dollars a year on simulators
uh spending berkshire hathaway money and
he never checks with alma he's never had
to come to omaha
for any kind of meetings he runs his own
business and that's what he loves in
life and i let him
do it i mean that's my contribution to
it is is really turning loose his
energies
and you know they were properly directed
before we bought the company seven or
eight years ago why do why should i
think that you know he couldn't keep
running it after that and like i said at
85 he's still running it
and that feeling of ownership
is really extraordinary and it's so much
better i mean it's the way i like to
work uh and it's the way you know it's
the way
susan jock likes to work it's the way al
yoshi likes to work somebody once said
that the chains of habit
are too light to be felt until they're
too heavy to be broken
i had been terrified of public speaking
i couldn't do it i'd throw up
and i knew if i didn't cure it then
i'd never cure it
and so i saw an ad in the paper for the
dale carnegie course
which worked on developing your ability
to speak in public
and i went down there
a good smile has the same effect as a
puppy's tail
they made us all these crazy things to
get out of ourselves and so we stood on
tables and did all kinds of things
[Music]
[Applause]
if i hadn't have done that
my whole life would have been different
[Music]
so in my office
you will not see the degree i got from
the university of nebraska you'll not
see the master's degree i got from
columbia university but you'll see the
little award certificate i got from the
dale carnegie of course
you have over a hundred billion dollars
of cash berkshire does that work
berkshire has over 100 billion in cash
and you say that you always want this
company to be a fortress
so how much cash should an ordinary
investor have on a percentage basis do
you think it depends on their personal
situation i mean it
uh
if
if
if you're working in something where
you're you're living off your your your
paycheck
from week to week
you want to have a little cash around
and and you certainly don't want to have
a credit card that's maxed out or
anything like that uh but if
you know if if your house is paid off
if you don't have big living expenses
you got a portfolio of
of
decent diversified businesses
uh
you really need any cash decent genes
for certain things and in my own case i
was sort of wired for capital allocation
and being wired for capital allocation a
couple hundred years ago in nebraska
wouldn't have been a thing
uh and and even now being born in
various parts of the world i wouldn't
have been much but here i was in this
soon-to-be very rich capitalistic system
and and it just so happened that what i
did paid off enormously in a market
system like we have and i if i'd had a
talent in some other area that was way
less commercial i mean i would have i
would have had a good time doing it but
it wouldn't have paid off like this but
of course jay said it perfectly when he
talked about
you know he's in the recording for
himself and the money comes afterwards i
mean i
i get to do what i love i mean and
it doesn't get any luckier than that if
if you can spend your lifetime and i'm
80 now and doing things you love every
single day i mean i would be doing what
i did and what i do now and i would have
done it in the past if the payoff had
been in seashells or sharksteen or
anything else
if you can go to work every morning i
tap dance to work you know and i come
down and i every day is exciting i i was
terrified for example
both in high school and college i don't
know when it started
but i became terrified of public
speaking and uh i just couldn't do it i
mean i and so i arranged all of my
classes so i never had to
do any public speaking and i got to
colombia
and i saw an ad in the paper
uh for dale carnegie course
and i went down it was somewhere in the
mid 40s and i gave the guy a check for
100 and i went back and stopped payment
i lost my nerve and then i came out
i got out of columbia actually when i
was 20 and i came out to start selling
securities in omaha
and i realized i had to get up and be
able to get up in front of people i
couldn't go through life this way so i
saw an ad again in the uh local paper
that there was a dale carnegie course
being given i went down and i gave the
fellow 100 in cash and
i became associated with 30 other people
in the class we couldn't stand up in
front of a group and say our own name i
mean it was we were it was pathetic but
that class changed my life in a big way
as a matter of fact
they used to give a pencil every week
for whoever did the most with what they
learned the previous week and during
that class i proposed to my wife and she
accepted and i won the pencil that week
so it it's important i mean there's
certain you've got to be able to
communicate in life and it's enormously
important and probably the schools to
some extent underemphasize that i mean
you get started going for an mba and
people think it's kind of beneath them
to teach about communication but if you
if you can't communicate if you can't
talk to other people and get across your
ideas or write you know you know you
you're giving up your potential and uh
you know anybody that's got a career
potential of x i guarantee it'll be 150
of x if they uh if they really learn how
to communicate well so that was that was
a big
a part of really succeeding in my career
if you want more top 10 videos they're
not on this channel anymore i have a
dedicated channel just for it go check
it out the link is right there next to
me continue to believe and i'll see you
there